hey guys I'm just McDonald and you are
joining me for my top-five show where I
bring you my five favorite gaming news
stories of the week to get you all
caught up on what's been happening first
up CD Projekt RED have said that they
won't let you down with cyberpunk 2077
as if they ever have before
Ciara Martin of in ski has quelled fan
concerns promising the upcoming game
will be a true RPG and not a straight-up
multiplayer shooter but ever
implementing some kind of multiplayer
though and while the vague is out and
flourishing they've said it will
certainly be a true RPG cyberpunk is
also set to be as open bold as you'd
expect from the guys who are making The
Witcher 3 in news of gigantic franchises
Microsoft has bought Pierce from epic
and obviously everybody just wanted to
know what questions you thought about it
Microsoft Studios subsidiary black tusk
studios will be taking over having
acquired the rights to gears and
Microsoft promises we'll hear more about
the franchise later this year theory
veteran Rod Fergusson has officially
joined Microsoft to help lead the studio
which should calm the nerves of any
worried Gears fans the main nerves
however seem to be related to the
concern over whether another geared game
would even be any good let me know what
you think Microsoft have said they are
super tired of talking about frame rates
and given that I have three to four
stories about them every single week I'm
sort of inclined to agree their product
planning director and dude who says
stuff that gets reported on even more
than phil spencer albert Panello has
said that people shouldn't get worked up
over 1080p and 60fps benchmarks whilst
on the gamertag radio podcast he also
said rise is the best looking game on
any platform and I think I'll leave it
up to you guys to check that one out
there was also a very complicated
metaphor from Aaron Greenberg about
movie screens which you can check out on
GameSpot but I don't have the time or
inclination
into it so do frame rates and
resolutions matter to you and what in
your opinion is the best looking game
ever in other Microsoft dnews the
publisher wants you to ditch your ps3
that's according to a promotion suss out
by an ear gap the email as suggests that
you ditch your ps3 and get $100 store
credit towards an xbox one so then it's
the price of a ps4 basically Microsoft's
want you to trade in your ps3 or your
Xbox 360s or a model in order to pick
yourself up the hot new Xbox product
just so you don't waste your time
dragging your chugging ps3 to your
nearest Microsoft Store though the
console must be in good working order
and you have to get it in before March
2nd to take advantage of the offer in
far and away the coolest thing that
happened this week the biggest space
battle to ever take place in EVE Online
happened and it's estimated to have cost
over five hundred thousand dollars in
damages essentially someone forgot to
pay the rent for this space station and
as predator Delphian one puts it
eloquently both sides escalated to the
current show over 100 Titans that is
really big ships were destroyed and
thousands of players participated which
racked up the massive losses the whole
situation is completely epic but I think
I'm on board with rather the sushi CW
who says Eve is the most fascinating
game that I have no intention of playing
let me know what you think about this or
any of the other stories that I brought
up today either in the comments down
below or you can do so on my Twitter
where I'm at jess mcdonald this week on
Spike you can check out zareen and i
guiltily killing innocent people in
house of horrors urban cam gets super
hungry and cold in Skyrim immersion mods
and the gist covers off on why you
should forgive watchdogs for its delay
those are all my favorite things that
happened this week but be sure to let me
know what yours are I'll be back next
week but until then I hope you have a
great weekend and I'll
she say